- Today I'm going to try to eat food
while wearing a face mask.
Why?
I have no idea.
- The real challenge is gonna be that
I'm not allowed to break any of this food,
I have to take a full bite.
- This is gonna be my new tinder photo.
- Ooh! Good thing I came hungry.
- Oh!
- Oh okay.
- Oh god.
- Level two, bring it on,
baby. Let's keep it going.
- I feel like this will
be easier than the popcorn
'cause you kinda just stick it back there.
- (laughing)
Oh boy.
- Uh oh, yeah
- (laughing) What is happening?
- I'm not thrilled about this one.
- (slurping)
- I'm just getting it everywhere
- (coughing)
- This is gonna be hard.
I feel like I need to prep the area.
- I can't even get it in!
- Sexy!
- No!
- I would like to stop doing this.
- This might be a personal low.
(music)